well back in first of all as your coach
are you trying to give me a heart attack
for yesterday the wife or yesterday it
was your like mistake you know I lost
the game so your loss was mine okay I'll
take it I'll take it he explained to us
uh today's game oh my God
at some point I I thought I was like
winning and I don't know what happened
so it was a successful opening it felt
whoa
[Laughter]
you're okay C6 F6 c66 yes that's pretty
decent
uh here okay uh Queen B6 I didn't like
this move Queen is not doing anything
like I felt like she had to play at
night somewhere like yeah night night of
six or night age six she needs to
develop and
um anyways and she has to somehow
protect these six Pawn so that's why I
thought after Queen B6 my position
should be winning because Knight G5 and
92 is coming
and it was indeed and I think her only
chance was something very unnatural to
go here here take a now long Castle
um
yeah yeah this one should be like this
one is definitely winning as well you
have to be a bit careful but it's still
winning
but then something happened yeah
something happened I wasn't sure about
A4 I I wanted to play immediately before
B4 okay yeah but I thought it would be
too much I don't know maybe I just had
to go for it it takes B Bishop E3 have
you have you learned about this thing
called development
take your pieces out
I've been told that if you can develop
with the temple it's always good yeah
some people will blame me that I'm not
teaching you development stuff all right
and you played this uh B4 or Cafe take
take
and I guess once again have you
irrelevant you know Bishop my original
idea was just to play Bishop E3 then we
got the position before we got position
at some point I just realized that I
have a very interesting move d4 the idea
is that if she takes on D4 then I'm
playing Bishop F4 so I'm developing the
bishop
[Laughter]
just giving him
it was just a beautiful move I I did
understand like after age six it's not
that clear
um but I thought my knight on H4 would
be better than a on G5 and she had time
trouble that's why I thought I'm putting
some pressure on her did you spot this
uh extra option of Knight to G4 for her
but I thought I'm better after 94 Knight
takes G6 or I'm playing Bishop F4 and
then Rook takes a four
then D3
oh
whoa what's your idea so the idea was
that if you take you you're not going to
take you're going to give a Chuck and
then Knight to E5
but okay it's it's difficult it's
already time on the clock to find it no
and still her king is not that safe no
no I would be glad to have this position
I don't care about the engine
it makes sense of course
um and she played Bishop E8 and it felt
like you're finally breaking through
right I wasn't sure if Bishop B8 was a
correct move like I didn't see I I had
the feeling that after Bishop B8 I'm
just winning because everything is
collapsing right and then I don't know
what I did wrong it just
I don't know well I think you know what
you did wrong Bishop E5 Rook B7 right F3
Rook f8
oh see oh my goodness
development oh please what is your queen
doing
um no I had this idea I don't know why I
thought after Bishop B6 and Bishop A6
I'm just winning I I totally missed
a salon move so you calculated Bishop
Texas yeah I thought I'm just winning I
didn't see any moves and I didn't have
much done that's why I decided to go for
it and then after I got the position I
was like oh my God what I'm gonna do
after we shoot this album
that was
that was bad
yes uh but you kept going and when did
you feel like you're getting some extra
chances once again at what point uh I
after I saw that uh I can play Rook 87
and Bishop uh C7 C7 I thought okay I'm
going for it but I I repeat it because I
I had like very low time
so basically this position I thought I'm
gonna win this position uh okay again
the engine can sure can hold it I do
believe it but like as a human how would
you play this position like your knight
a little bit stuck and I'm taking the
three Pawn anyways and you have uh like
weak pawns G6 and then H6 I I just
didn't see how she's gonna like uh play
I couldn't see the setup for her so I
was like probably I'm gonna win this
position so given that you did miss that
move Bishop to D7 you managed to
readjust psychologically and still play
for a win I was happy to have a player
like uh I wasn't forced to just repeat
the news that's uh that's why I was like
okay if I have a chance I'm just gonna
try absolutely and then you got into
this and Bishops of opposite color
opposition I'm not sure about 93 but it
felt like after 93 I have huge chances
to win the game okay like yeah I should
be very careful I shouldn't miss this H4
idea and I need to place my uh Bishop on
D6 which uh like which always holds
because of E6 that was my idea before I
played Knight B6 93 I imagined that I I
play C5 Bishop D6 G3 and King goes to F6
and that's how I should be winning
I don't know like yeah let's go towards
that moment because it did he found some
good uh like moves I guess and here she
played this move King too yes that was a
disaster like King needs to stay on this
King to C6 and how are you planning on
trying to make progress at this point
um probably I'll put King on a F5 okay
now it seems like Bishop to E8 might be
the only move
which is not amazing move through
to
make
your idea is to play Bishop D7 and King
D5 that's how you want to hold it yes I
also thought if I can like if she can
get that position she has like but what
if you push your Pawn all the way to E6
now
and this is the key now you have it
seems H4
mm-hmm
now it works for some reason yeah
well she didn't find it she played them
of King to E6 and after that she didn't
have time to find anything she did not
yes yes she did it's a huge Factor
that's why I just went to this end game
okay I'm not like it's not easy for her
uh to play this and I'm not forcing
anything
so she needs to find moons in like 30
seconds it's like insanely hard in the
in such positions I guess it's easy to
blunder
congratulations back him a big victory
uh bounce back victory for you after
yesterday's loss how would you assess
your performance so far oh yesterday was
a disaster I was marching my king on e4
which was which was a great idea I'm
happy about my idea even today about
like B4 and D4 moves I'm finding some
good uh like ideas beautiful moves to
play but I'm not like
uh finishing of my opponents uh yeah
yesterday it was adjustable under I I
meant to play G6 first but for some
reason I thought like king after is not
good I was looking for other moves and
it was just a blunder like I forgot
about Jesus idea so so far it's all
right a win is a win two out of three
still in third position right now thank
you patience beg him can I ask a
question
I know that vegan she comes from chess
family her father plays chess her
sisters everybody fully chest and even
though they're in Uzbekistan right now
do they follow the tournament I mean are
they checking your games online or they
do it next day I mean of course like my
family everyone like checks my games my
results but sometimes it's too late I
guess uh like now it's two or three a.m
there so probably
my sisters are not watching but my dad
might be watching so he's my huge fan he
always watched my games at life yes do
you feel their support when you play any
Tournament of course I I just know that
they are always by my side they they
have been like my whole life huge
support for me I know that they are for
me all the time yeah and the last
question like begging played on the
first board for the national team and I
was wondering like does it do you feel
like extra responsibility now that you
kind of need to prove something maybe
even win this Championship no I never
feel like I'm responsible to prove some
something to someone else other than me
so other than myself
I'm just playing here uh I think I'm
just like as others trying to play in my
past chest that's all I don't I never
thought about like oh I had the first
sport I have to like show something you
know okay thank you and congratulations
thank you so much guys absolutely our
congratulations indeed